what's his income at the insurance
company well he just resigned from that
position because after he took it over
he ran it into the ground he couldn't
make a go of it right now he's doing a
sales job and uh it seems to be going
pretty well but he's only been doing it
a couple of months he's making about
75,000 a year plus bonuses I hear your
disgust for his behavior in your voice
and I also hear I also hear a dad that
loves his son even though he's been
stupid I think that he's grown and I
think that he makes a living it's he's
not making he's not poverty level
there's nothing wrong with him I think
he just needs to be a man and do man
things I totally agree with you and I
think you're a great dad